مستشارو الامن القومي لاكثر من 80 دوله
حضروا الى منتجع دافوس في سويسرا اجتمعوا
حول مقترح للسلام في اوكرانيا اقترحه
الرئيس فلاديمير زيلنسكي شارك في اداره
النقاش مدير مكتب الرئيس الاوكراني ووزير
الخارجيه السويسري الذي اقر بعدم
الاستعداد لضم روسيا الى
المحادثات بطريقه او باخرى سنحتاج الى
ايجاد طريقه لاشراك روسيا في العمليه لن
يكون هناك سلام دون ان يكون لروسيا كلمتها
لتقولها لكن بالنسبه لاوكرانيا المحادثات
كانت
بناءه اجرينا محادثات مفتوحه وبناءه
للغايه وناقشنا بالتفصيل المبادئ الاساسيه
لاثراء السلام الشامل والعادل والدائم
لاوكرانيا وفي جميع انحاء
العالم المحادثات ركزت على عده نقاط
اعتماد معايير لوضع حد للاعمال العدائيه
انسحاب القوات الروسيه تحقيق العداله اثر
الجرائم المرتكبه ومنع اي تصعيد جديد وزير
الخارجيه السويسري شدد ايضا على اهميه
مشاركه البرازيل والهند وجنوب افريقيا في
المفاوضات بسبب وجودها الى جانب روسيا ضمن
مجموعه بريكس